tu as 21 ans toi tu es originaire de
mulhouse et était un ancien espoir du
football dont on parcours est très
intéressant on m'a vendu 1 un
footballeur né repéré par des centres de
formation en europe tu y avait un rêve
et qu'il l'a toujours être dans le
milieu du foot que ce soit sur ou hors
du terrain la vie en a décidé autrement
tu vas nous expliquer ton parcours
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour toi
lorenzo moi j'ai commencé le foot très
tôt à l'âge de 5 6 ans je vais commencer
avec des cousins moi qui m'ont mis un
peu dans le bas j'ai direct était addict
je vais au foot ou le temps je me
faisais engueuler tout le temps parce
que je jouais la maison de la chambre
qui passait tout après j'ai intégré un
club qui mettait en avant les jeunes on
était nous né on est frontalier avec la
avec l'allemagne moi je vais souvent en
allemagne en suisse ou si j'ai très vite
été surclassé dans les catégories où tu
bouges avec les plus grands et on est
entraîneur on commence à me pousser à
essayer de partir un peu de la zone
parce que c'est très fermée chez nous et
et en même temps j'avais j'avais l'école
qui prenait un peu de place même quand
on est jeune ça prend de la place et
j'avais un père qui lui pour me pousser
dans le milieu parce qu'il connaît c'est
un ancien sportif aussi et j'ai plutôt
une maman qui était un peu toujours il
faut il rester scolaire passe ton bac
d'abord voilà étude le sport c'est un
loisir s'appelle connais tous les mamans
c'est à peu près le cas elles ont toutes
voilà c'est ça et j'ai eu une
opportunité à l'âge de 12 ans j'ai été
recruté par un parent club espagnol qui
s'appelle le fc seville lors d'un
tournoi à bâle ah oui quand même et mon
père était complètement fou
de
rentrer à la maison
en criant fallait pas 10 ans de
l'espagne
et ma mère étaient un peu choqués la
comprenais pas avec un iphone tout ce
milieu là c'est pas ce que ça peut
apporter surtout aujourd'hui on sait que
le foot voilà c'est une des plus grandes
industries du sport très grand mais
c'est effectivement et ce à partir de là
qu'il commence à avoir des petites
petites embrouilles ma mère voulait pas
me laisser partir mon père lui voulait
me laisser partir moi j'étais au milieu
de tout ça et est ce que j'ai oublié de
dire aussi le plus important c'est que
en 2009 moi j'ai mon père qui est tombé
gravement malade il a fait deux très
grosses crises d'épilepsie qui sont
enchaînés sur des tumeurs du cancer et
tout ça et moi j'étais jeune je
comprenais pas ce qui - moi je
comprenais pas ce qui expliquait aussi
du coup pourquoi ta maman voulait rester
à la maison moi j'ai du recul manar je
le comprends ça mais quand j'avais 10 11
12 ans je n'ai pas certain quand on perd
même poussé à
et après il s'en est sorti c'était
n'était pas très bon au début et après
c'est une maladie m'a heureusement qu'il
ya beaucoup de rechute ouais beaucoup de
récidive est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
et moi je commence à grandir je commence
sa part à comprendre ce qui ce qui se
passait et je commençais tout doucement
sans le savoir à mettre le foot de côté
mon rêve avec et à l'école ça suivait
pas parce que je rentrais chez moi le
soir je savais pas si j'allais voir mon
père à la maison ou si je devais aller
voir l'hôpital c'était des années des
années maladie dans les hôpitaux c'était
que ça c'était limite si défendre mais
pas avec à l'hôpital bien sûr et
moelleux amwaj à l'est en cours et ça a
été ça pendant tout le jour montre match
après j'ai commencé à aller dans les
études au lycée j'ai intérêt d'ailleurs
un sport études avec parce que je
voulais quand même
essayé pour qu'il arrive je faisais un
bac général us à côté et si jali
mon père le bac us le sport études vous
pouvez plus tu es trop c'était trop et
du coup
mon bac il a commencé un peu à à
s'échapper pourtant sport-études avait
une bonne moyenne j'ai pratiquement 12
de moyenne générale en sport-études mais
ce n'était pas suffisant j'ai redoublé
et quand tu redouble un sport-études tu
peux pas le refaire du coup j'ai quitté
le parcours son étude monsieur vraiment
c'est en génère ben s et c'est là que ça
commence à être une catastrophe j'ai
perdu ma grand-mère donc la mère de mon
père en 2016 et c'est là qu'il a fait
une rechute terrible
c'était hôpital sur l'hôpital des mois
des mois et que tu aies jamais à la
maison j'avais ma mère en parallèle qui
elle tombée malade aussi son côté elle
travailler plus donc elle est à la
maison c'est ça vous viviez avec du coup
très peu par mois pour eux pour été
franchement est à 800 euros par mois
pour 3 parce que mon père soit ce
n'était pas là il était à l'hôpital et
pendant des années pendant des années
c'était comme ça et gérer les cours avec
c'était très compliqué donc j'allais en
cours je rigolais je faisais le clown
mais
bien sur une façade bien sûr en course
n'était pas dedans je pense à mon père
tout le temps mais j'entendais les
pompiers je crois que c'est mon père qui
était d'en face tout le temps comme ça
et en 2018 il a fait un bail grave
rechute il est tombé dans un coma
les médecins sont venus nous voir ne se
dit pas c'est terminé
ces voix là il avait retenu comme il a
plu c'est fini donc moi je rentre chez
moi on commence à apprécier toute la
famille et à trois du matin on me dit
mais en fait il est sorti du coma c'est
vrai guerrier un américain un miracle on
y retourne et le plus impressionnant
c'est qu'ils font les échographies tout
ça et ne disent mais ce qu'on comprend
pas ce qui a plus trace de cancer en
deux jours alors selon vous il ya deux
jours il ya dix ans une nuit vous nous
dit c'est fini il a remporté irait et en
fait c'était un constant combat il
voulait toujours être là pour pour nous
parce qu'il nous avait promis en fait à
ma petite soeur et moi de rester là
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce qu'on ait nos études
qu'on est nous après voilà avec du recul
il pouvait pas il a su comme il pouvait
et donc là il a commencé à se remettre
2018 moi je passais mon bac non je
pensais me relancer moi aussi mon côté
dans le foot non dans le bac avec mon
père est ça et il a fait de la
rééducation des malheureusement bain en
2019 il a refait une rechute et là
c'était fini ça a touché les ménages
donc ce qui est ton père est décédé en
2010 elle en novembre 2019 du coup il
est parti et ça a été dix ans de combat
de malades y est pour lui pour nous
aussi du coup
voilà c'était c'est très compliqué
encore aujourd'hui parce que moniteur si
c'était mon mécène ou pilier c'était un
super 5 gt sincère
avec vous pouvez vous n'avez pas de
problème je suis quelqu'un de très
pudique sont mes sentiments l'ust j'ai
perdu un pilier dans la vie et je sais
que l'une des dernières phrases qui m'a
dit c'est que ces rêves était devenu
l'hymne et enfin mes rêves et et de
musiciens plus tôt et du coup il voulait
absolument que que j'ai réussi dans le
football et il m'a dit tu vois arriver
et c'est pour ça que va partir de là je
mangeais commence à me relancer
bon bien sûr j'ai pas eu mon bac parce
que j'étais tellement ailleurs ça ça
tout le monde peut le comprendre mais
effectivement tu n'as rien lâcher des
gens présentent tous nos condoléances
même si c'était en 2019 on comprend que
ce soit encore très compliqué merci de
nous livrer ce témoignage donc tu n'as
pas eu son bac mais tu t'es démené et a
même trouvé des petits emplois pour pour
subsister et tu n'as pas abandonner ce
rêve et a envie de rendre fiers ton papa
malgré tout je suis je suis très ému
parce que j'ai je vais te présenter
cédric kristen qui va nous rejoindre sur
le plateau
[Musique]
cédric ryssen qui est coprésident du
touquet athletic club club de football
évoluant en nationale 3 et qui est
notamment fondateur du pôle ressources
un groupement d'associations dans
l'insertion la mobilité le handicap
l'environnement dans la région du
touquet cédric vous avez écouté le
témoignage de lorenzo comme vous tous
comme vous tous à la maison qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez lui lui dire ce soir là
plein de choses c'est vrai que en
entendant ça on a envie de de t'aider à
te lancer à écrire une nouvelle page
nous au club du touquet on a lancé un
programme qui s'appelle le programme
seconde chance et je pense que tu ailles
parfaitement dans ce programme on
aimerait accueillir mais très rapidement
ce programme consiste à accueillir des
jeunes qui ont raté parfois la dernière
marche du centre de formation ou qui ont
eu des accidents de la vie je pense que
tu entres dans cette catégorie on
aimerais te donner une chance dans avec
un programme spécifique un programme
digne d'un club professionnel
de te donner une chance réellement de
refaire des essais dans le monde du
football dans le monde professionnel sur
l'année en cours donc on fait ça de
façon assez rapide et comme vous l'avez
dit le le club de football fait partie
d'un pôle le pôle ressource qui compte
une dizaine d'associations qui
travaillent dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire sur le territoire du
montreuillois est donc là ce que
j'aimerais te proposer c'est de rentrer
en immersion au sein de ces associations
donc c'est des associations qui
travaillent dans le numérique qui
travaillent dans la lutte contre le
handicap contre les discriminations le
tourisme inclusif on a également des
structures d'insertion est ce que ce
qu'on va faire et je vais t'accompagner
dans cette démarche c'est faire un
diagnostic de ce que tu as envie de
faire dans la nuit parce que nous ce
programme seconde chance au club de
football je ne vais pas vendre aussi
bien le football que tu as pu vendre le
golf tout à l'heure sur plusieurs de mes
mais le football oui mais avec un
travail je pense que déjà quand on sort
d'un centre de formation je crois qu'il
ya une probabilité d'un pour cent
de devenir footballeur professionnel
donc il faut absolument que tu emboîte
le pas dans le monde professionnel et
donc c'est immersion au sein de toutes
ces associations
ça te permettent de tagger pour qu'on
ait rapidement une orientation et
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux